so why are you wearing the work fest if
you're not working
i'm wearing the vest because
it keeps my lie going with my family
they think i'm going out to work
i haven't worked in three weeks
my mom thinks i'm working my son thinks
i'm working
and what i'm doing is just going to hang
out on fig
and do drugs
it's gotten to the point to where now um
i'm not even getting my edd anymore that
was canceled because someone broke into
my account
but anyway and i haven't even
because of the cause of the drugs i
haven't even tried to go down to the
unemployment office and correct it
i'm basically
borrowing money from people telling them
that i'm going to pay them back
because i when i had getting the edd
when i was working
i was able to do that
and you know i had money to buy what i
wanted to buy
but now
since i don't have a job and not getting
evd
i'm still portraying
like i'm doing good and i'm not
so you're wearing the vest to make it
look like you i'm wearing the vest
basically
to when i leave home
to let my mother and my son think that
i'm going to work
and i borrow money like for gas
but they keep asking me when my check is
going to come
keeps the cops off your back too
yeah but mainly i'm wearing it because
it gives me a chance to
get out the house
get money
stay out and don't have like i have an
excuse you understand
but the thing about this is i don't i'm
not bringing home any money
i'm taking money
from the family
you know nothing
no it's
forty fifty dollars here ten dollars
here the life that i need gas i had to
go far to unload a truck
and there's no not doing that anymore
so i'm in a web of lies and and i'm
saying
i don't even know how to
i know what i want to do is come
straight out and just be honest
with my family but
i'm involved now with people that
they come and bring me drugs because
of what i know in my knowledge
they're using me
instead of paying me i'm accepting drugs
i got
one two three dope dealers
that i've done there
edd
i've done their ppp
and now i'm doing the rental agreement
that on the process they're paying me
drugs and not money
there's only when one guy that's not a
drug dealer
that actually has given me money
but then it ended up where now i owe him
money because i didn't borrow money and
i'm doing his edd
but now i'm not
it's just a big web of lies that this
has brought me into
and the worst thing about it is that
my mother
hadn't brought her into it because now
i know she knows
but i think it's her love for me that
just makes her just gives me the money
because i'm not telling i need this for
gaston
and
and i know
she knows because when she asks me when
i'm going to get my check i get very
angry
like i always say
[ __ ] like
oh well
they're gonna direct deposit
or
they mailed it and i've been doing that
now for about maybe three weeks
and now
even i can't be at home at peace
because i got people coming in my house
that want to want me to do searches like
you know for their stimulus checks and
stuff like that because i know how to
irs and the 1040 and
individual taxes they come over
and i'll go through the process like you
know get my payment get my refund and
that they don't they're just giving me
um
getting me dope and it's like this
now i'm to the point to where
i can't even rest at my own house
people are knocking on my window at
three a.m in the morning
you know and you know my mother is way
back in the back room my son's in the
middle i'm in the front room
but they'll come they'll come in and
females and sell drugs and we sit there
we get high
and it's like
i'm not it's to the point that now i
really don't really even know like
10 20 that ain't nothing
these people i can't even get away from
it where even i don't i don't have any
money they come over and get me high
it's like i have never ever
seen
a situation with decision with how long
i've been doing it where now i i can be
broke as a joke
and drugs just come like it just comes
somebody comes over
or i could tell somebody that okay well
uh i'm gonna do that stimulus thing for
you know throw me at 20. i if i initiate
it but most time i don't
they come over to check oh
because another thing the way that
because i certify people every two weeks
and once a week and when i certify them
they give me though
i got four clients that i do that for
you're too well connected
yeah
[Music]
and i keep saying
i'm tired of being used i'm gonna cut
them off
because i want to start you know
i want to stop doing the edd and
certifying people i've actually tried to
let people show them how to do it on
their phones but too [ __ ] lazy
because i'm doing it for them and their
money keeps coming okay but now
it's coming to an end
they're asking me about reopening cases
i'm doing the research that they don't
do because they don't know
they're using me
but now
it's to the point to where i can't take
care of my business
my cable was cut off
i'm having problems with other bills
my car note
it's to the point to where and it's like
every day my mother has something to say
or a letter or someone's calling about
monies being old
now when i was having my just break mom
off break brandon off and i'll keep what
i had to do to go smoke get high and
mess around with the women right i
remember the last time i was here i was
talking about how i used to pick them up
and drive them around they pay me but
see now
i'm back doing that again
because i know that i've been stressed
out my family but i'm still doing the
same thing like say if i ain't got it
i'm gonna stress them out
my family
i'm a [ __ ] fraud
i hate myself
because
my mom loves me and i'm and my son loves
me
and they
and i know i'm not fooling them
they're just doing and giving me because
they love me
but i know that's gonna come to an end
i got the people
now
i got a friend she's a female
she is say
she's a dope leader
but she's like 51.50
the most [ __ ] starting person you ever
seen in your life
she comes over almost every
night about 1am she don't even call she
just shows up
because hey patrick you know i want to
check this out boom goes in my room i
close the door my mom knows her she
she's actually gotten in good with my
mom because she buys my mom
my mom likes fish like you know fish
dinners and stuff so she'll buy my
mother fish dinners and stuff like that
and my mom likes it but my mom
doesn't really know what she's about
then i can be calm peaceful
rested and
once she comes over
bam
i gotta have more it's almost like
it's almost like
she's doing it on purpose
and believe me if
the intelligence of this woman
she can i have to explain everything to
the irs about her business
and get her money
she needs me
and i'm just letting people take
advantage of me and it's actually taking
advantage of my home oh my god
the lion
i don't even know i had a
and i'm lying because i'm going to get
tell them how to put gas in my tank to
go here and go there and basically i'll
take and get two or three dollars and
then go buy something that's after the
person came over and got me high
and my situation now is just getting
worse and worse because i'm not taking
care of my business
at all
i'm not
what i'm doing for them
i'm supposed to be doing for myself you
understand there's and and
there's jobs out there
i'm an i.t person i told you where i
graduated from
i'm good at it but i'm not even trying
to look for a job in my field
my son just tells me
when you're going to go back into
computers
right now i'm just doing this
stuff for people
but i haven't
i haven't did a repair on a computer in
so long but i know software and i know
how to
you know contact people and talk and
i've gotten some people something like
well one person i got them 21 000 on
their edd
and they still act like i hold them
oh i paid you i paid you what about the
dope i gave you
i don't even feel
right now i feel
i don't even know who i am
and then i try to talk and be aggressive
and woo
but still
it's something that you know what you
said mark and i know this i you know
you're not telling me something i don't
know
you can't just talk
you got to show it
i look at myself i look at the people
that i'm around and what i'm doing
um
i'm afraid that i'll be the one sleeping
in the tent one day you understand
i'll be there
on the street
pissing and [ __ ] on the side and
[ __ ] like that
i've even learned how to talk now and
panhandle gas
you know get gas money
just so i can get down here
to give somebody a ride
so dope
i'm getting more violent
getting more angry
to the point to where
i'll take it out on anybody or not
anybody but
i've never ever
i mean i'm not a person a bully or
anything like that i've never been
i've always gotten bullied but now i'm
starting to be very aggressive
you know
very very aggressive
like
like they are
you know and that [ __ ] like would
never
d i would never deal with that one okay
it was a loss boom i got money coming
but now i'm getting aggressive to where
getting my [ __ ] money you know
i'm you know i'm i'm becoming a
[ __ ]
street person gangster
[Music]
my mom is old
i lost my dad she's the only one i got
i know i need to stand up
i figured i was okay now let me go ahead
and they got the new um
rental uh uh the california
kovac 19
rental relief
i figured that's going to help me bring
in some money in the house you know
saying my mom's led lauren paying the
rent and i did that i'm doing that now
but see i'm so
[ __ ] up
that i haven't even completed
my application i've done somebody else's
to get paid and money
and here i haven't even done mine
and and my [ __ ] is legit my mother owns
the house she can be the landlord and
get landlord assistant i can pay rent
where i should have been paying
you know to help out the house bring
money into the house i'm too busy
running around
with this [ __ ]
[Music]
what's your biggest regret
lying to my mom
she's so
just
bringing those peoples over bringing
people to my house
that i never would bring to my house in
the first place that wouldn't even those
people coming in
doing that [ __ ]
that's what i regret the most
and then i regret also that my son
even though he's doing well he's working
and he's going to veterinary school but
still
guns
i caught i came in one day and there was
a gun
i pick it up i pull the clip
i tell the dude you know whose gun is
there's a gun i'm like this this is
stupid who puts a gun on the trunk and
and is way over there if you first of
all if you have a gun you're gonna put
it on yourself and you ain't gonna let
nobody know you have it and this is not
the first incident that
what has happened is is that now
well the first incident was when
brandon even know a gun was in his car
a guy left the gun in his car
i'm in the back seat
my friend his friend's in the front
brandon's driving something comes and
comes off under the seat i'm thinking
that it's like a damn like a uh
a pipe wrench or something but when i
reached out and grabbed it i knew
exactly what it was and i touched it
it was on the blacks i took it out and
like then what the [ __ ] is this brandon
and then
he didn't know it was there
he didn't he didn't know he turned many
u-turn i told man you gotta strive right
because we don't know
okay we can catch a case
and it seems like
he ain't listening to me because of what
i'm doing
and i've always
i just would like to be i just would
like to go home and just tell my mother
all this [ __ ]
but it would hurt her
i know she i feel like she already knows
i mean
she's
how many times can you sell the same
[ __ ] you can should lie about gas
money
how many times you could tell the same
[ __ ] you should lie about why you
didn't get your check
i don't i don't know what i'm gonna say
now i don't know what to say next
what i should do
i should tell everybody
because i don't owe nobody
that i'm not i'm not [ __ ] with them
i'm finished
i know the only way they're going to
stop messing with me if i say
i'm not getting high anymore but see now
they always know
give me some dope
and now
also with the women
i'm requiring more
where you know what sexual favors
sometimes i'll ask for sexual favors
other than money
and sexual favor is dope
so now you know i don't know i i
and then i bring home food
is because i've taken people out
to boost you know what that is
i do that and but it ain't food that i
went and bought this food that they just
stole saying look man this is what i
bought
with the money you gave me
[Music]
mark i
i don't know
when i came here the first time and i
talked
it did i change i started you know i
changed but now i've allowed it to come
back into my life
and now where i was
boom boom boom i don't have to worry
about listen i don't have to have a
[ __ ] dime dog and it [ __ ] comes
you hear me it comes
because the dope dudes that i mess with
they smoke
you see
but they've gotten to the point where
they can buy a sack boom but they'll
throw me a 40. some don't
but the ones that do
i don't have to
[ __ ] go out there and chase it like i
you chase it like that but i do because
now i want to get out and you know start
chasing it when you know you know what
i'm talking about you know
the sex thing
but i can't even sit at my own house
i can't sit in my house for two days
without somebody coming by
offering me drugs to do something for
them their edd
or their
taxes
or their
uh uh
the rent relief because now you know
certain
cities
didn't get this program because they had
their own program
so so the city of
my city and the other city compton they
get it
so people now they're trying to make up
addresses and [ __ ] trying to say that
this person's their landlord and i'm
actually
i'm doing it for them
if they could so i'm actually committing
the crime for them you understand but
i'm showing them how they can do it and
get it you understand
but it's in their name but i'm the one
that's doing
they wouldn't know how to do it
because
i will and when i want to i will sit
back and research
for them
all the research i've done
i applied to them and not myself
i don't need the only thing i need them
for
is for drugs
they can't help me out
with anything as far as business
as far as trying to make money
entrepreneurship they can't help me out
with anything only thing they can give
me is drugs
they can't even give me no [ __ ]
advice
some can you know i got some homeboys
you know my big homie he can he he he
he's very smart
he's intelligent
but the ones the other ones they can't i
had one of them try to tell me
how to
deal with my son
their son is breaking out their windows
and and all kind of [ __ ] and you want
and they're trying to actually give me
advice on how to talk to my son
me and my son haven't
had no riff but now he's not really
talking because he's not a fool he's
very intelligent and i raised him to be
intelligent i stayed on him so he ain't
no dummy
he knows
because i love because he loves me
he'll let me get away with it but then
sometimes he don't but sometimes he does
and the people that come to my house
i mean
yeah
like
the one that we were supposed to bring
me here before
that is coming to my house
that is coming in my room that is laying
up in my bed
there any lessons you're learning from
all of this
i'm learning that
if i don't
do something and do something fast
i'll be in a tent like the [ __ ]
but i don't want to down there because
what do because i'm doing it but that's
the place
that i want to be and that's a place
where i've actually i didn't i go there
and kick back now a little bit you know
what i mean why you didn't do it and get
high i had a little bit more
all i'm saying is that it does what the
same thing everybody brings down
and i'm trying to fight it but me the
facade
somebody once told me that you the worst
thing you ever can do is start believing
your own lies
all right reggie thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you um
like before maybe this will
talking about it
getting it out because you know they say
that
you know when you're in
the program you're supposed to write
that [ __ ] out get it out of you
maybe this has helped me
i hope so
thank you goodbye appreciate it thanks
so now you understand mark